a major scientific question is to be
able to predict what shape and RNA will
fold into in practice and we know that
our models aren't good enough to do this
so we have computer models but they
don't explain how RNA is fold in
practice and what a scientist would
really do is perform experiments and see
how those experiments work and then
repeat and so on and so forth and what
eterna does is open up this whole
scientific cycle to the public and allow
them to propose experiments see the
results and then propose more
experiments and ultimately we hope help
us generate hypotheses about Wynn RNAs
fold the way they do and why they do so
just like basketball where you score by
throwing a ball through a hoop in Eterna
you score if the RNA you design folds
properly in the lab so it's a completely
new kind of scoring mechanism and we're
really excited about what this means as
a new kind of game and a new kind of way
to make scientific progress there's no
questions of referees or whether the
balls in or out because you're scored
based on the laws of nature